buenas noches lo que ha anunciado
demuestra que los conservadores quieren
elegir al primer ministro del reemplazo
brace johnson lo más rápido posible por
ello estas noches han modificado sus
reglas de este proceso de elección para
que sea de semanas y no de meses mañana
abrirán y cerrarán las candidaturas
entonces el miércoles empezará la
primera ronda de eliminación y luego el
jueves es importante que para esta etapa
en esta elección del 2022 los diputados
para que puedan tener una real opción de
candidatura necesitan el respaldo de al
menos 20 otros diputados se prevé que la
próxima semana muy posiblemente el lunes
queden dos candidatos dos finalistas
entonces ellos durante el verano en
agosto iniciarán una gira por todo el
país luego las bases del partido
conservador serán convocadas para que
puedan votar y el anuncio del nuevo
primer ministro como lo has resaltado
será el lunes 5 de septiembre y entonces
boris johnson tendrá que dejar country
de iniciará una nueva etapa o una nueva
época para este país luisa al día de hoy
quienes son los postulados a suceder a
bordillos
hay 11 candidatos hasta el momento pero
este martes cerrarán entonces las
candidaturas la posibilidad de
inscripciones entonces puede aumentar o
bajar lo cierto es que en esta lista de
11 candidatos hay hasta el momento 3
ministros de estado del actual gabinete
de boris johnson sobre ellos la ministra
de exteriores el ministro de transporte
y el recién designado ministro de
finanza sorpresivamente esta noche se
han revelado encuestas que muestran que
los conservadores las bases y los
diputados tienen como favoritos a penny
mordente que fue la primera ministra de
defensa mujer del reino unido también el
ex ministro de finanzas- ricci sunat que
renunció el martes y generó todo este
terremoto político por el que boris
johnson tuvo que renunciar y
sorpresivamente también
tom doggett ham que es el secreto el
director de asuntos exteriores del
parlamento y sirvió como miembro de las
fuerzas militares en la guerra de
afganistán ellos lograrían ese apoyo de
20 diputados para pasar a la siguiente
etapa pero lo flexible de esta elección
conservadora es que puede haber muchas
sorpresas así que habrá que esperar
también están postulándose estadilla bit
jeremy hunt suela braverman que me va de
bart y richard city